so what about artificial intelligence
would it be uh
the ems the emulated minds
what idea
what whether
that struck you
in the shower one day
or
well are they you just clearly the
biggest view quake in artificial
intelligence is the realization of just
how complicated our human minds are so
most people who come to artificial
intelligence from other fields or from
relative ignorance
a very common phenomenon which you must
be familiar with is that they come up
with some concept and then they think
that must be it
once we implement this new concept we
will have it we will have full human
level or higher artificial intelligence
right and they're just
not appreciating just how big the
problem is how long the road is just how
much is involved because that's actually
hard to appreciate when we just think it
seems really simple
and studying artificial intelligence
going through many particular problems
looking at each problem all the
different things you need to be able to
do to solve a problem like that
makes you realize all the things your
minds are doing that you are not aware
of that's that vast subconscious that
you're not aware that's the biggest view
k from artificial intelligence by far
for most people who study artificial
intelligence is to see
just how hard it is i think uh that's a
good point but i think it's a it's a
very early view quake it's when the uh
uh sure done in kruger crashes
hard it's the first realization that
humans are actually quite incredible the
human mind the human body is quite
there's a lot of different parts to it
but then
see i it's already been so long for me
that i've experienced that view quake
that for me
i now experience a few quakes of holy
[ __ ] this little thing is actually quite
powerful like neural networks i'm amazed
because
you've become
more cynical after that first view quake
of like this is so hard like evolution
did some incredible work to create a
human mind but then you realize just
because you have you've talked about a
bunch of simple models that simple
things can actually be extremely
powerful that maybe uh emulating of the
human mind is extremely difficult but
you can go a long way with a large
neural network you can go a long way
with a dumb solution it's that stuart
russell thing with the reinforcement
learning
right holy crap you can do you can go a
long way with us but we still have a
very long road to go but nonetheless i
can't i refuse to sort of know the the
road
the road is full of surprises so long
sure is an interesting like you said
with the six
hard steps that humans have to take to
arrive at where we are from the origin
of life on earth
so it's long maybe in the
statistical improbability of the steps
that have to be taken
but in terms of how quickly those steps
could be taken
i don't
know if my intuition says it's
if it's hundreds of years away or if
it's
uh
a couple of years away i prefer to
measure pretty confidence at least a
decade and well we can file that
confidence at least three decades i can
steal man either direction
i prefer to measure that journey in elon
musk's that's the new uh we don't get
elon musk very often so that's that's a
long time scale for now i don't know
maybe you can clone or maybe multiply or
even know what elon musk
what that is what is that what is that's
a good question exactly
well that's an excellent question how
does that and then how does that fit
into the model the three parameters
that are required for becoming a grabby
alien civilization so that's the
question of how much any individual
makes in the long path of civilization
over time
yes and you know it's a favorite topic
of historians and people to try to like
focus on individuals and how much of a
difference they make and certainly some
individuals make a substantial
difference in the modest term
right
uh like you know certainly without
hitler being hitler in the role he took
european history would have taken a
different path for for a while there
but if we're looking over like many
centuries longer term things most
individuals do fade in their individual
influence
so
i mean einstein you and einstein
[Applause]
no matter how sexy your hair is you will
also be forgotten in the long arc of
history uh so you said at least 10 years
so let's talk a little bit about
this ai point
um of where how we achieve how hard is
the problem of solving intelligence
uh by engineering artificial
intelligence that achieves human level
human-like qualities that we associate
with intelligence how hard is this what
are the different trajectories that take
us there
one way to think about it is in terms of
the scope of the technology space you're
talking about so
let's take the biggest possible scope
all of human technology right the entire
human economy so the entire
economy is composed of many industries
each of which have many products with
many different technologies supporting
each one
at that scale i think we can accept that
um
most innovations are a small fraction of
the total that is usually has relatively
gradual overall progress
and that individual innovations
that are have a substantial effect the
total are rare and their total effect is
still a small percentage of the of the
total economy right there's very few
individual innovations that
made a substantial difference to the
whole economy right what are we talking
steam engine you know shipping
containers you know a few things
uh shipping shipping containers deserves
to be up there with steam engines
honestly
uh can you say exactly why shipping
containers
shipping containers revolutionized
shipping and shipping is very important
but placing that as shipping containers
so you're saying you wouldn't have some
of the magic of the supply chain and all
that without shipping containers that
made a big difference absolutely
interesting that's something to look
into i don't i we shouldn't we shouldn't
take that tangent although i'm tempted
to but anyway so there's a few just a
few innovations right so at the scale of
the whole economy right
now as you move down to a much smaller
scale um you will see individual
innovations having a bigger effect
right so if you look at i don't know
lawn mowers or something
i don't know about the innovations lawn
mower but there are probably like steps
where you just had a new kind of
lawnmower and that made a big difference
to mowing lawns
because you're you're focusing on a
smaller part of the whole technology
space right so
um
and you know sometimes like military
technology there's a lot of military
technology there's a lot of small ones
but every once in a while a particular
military weapon like makes a big
difference
but still even so mostly overall they're
making modest differences to a something
that's increasing relatively stable like
us military is the strongest in the
world consistently for a while no one
weapon in the last 70 years has like
made a big difference in terms of the
overall prominence of the us military
right because that's just saying even
though every once in a while even the
recent soviet hyper missiles or whatever
they are they aren't
changing the overall balance
dramatically right
so when we get to ai now the now i can
frame the question how big is ai
basically if so one way of thinking
about ai is it's just all mental tasks
and then you ask what fraction of tasks
are mental tests and then i go a lot
and then if i think of ai is like half
of everything
then i think well it's got to be
composed of lots of parts where anyone
innovation is only a small impact right
now if you think no no no ai is like agi
and then you think
agi is a small thing right there's only
a small number of key innovations that
will enable it
now you're thinking there could be
a bigger
chunk that you might find that would
have a bigger impact so the way i would
ask you to frame these things in terms
of the chunkiness of different areas of
technology
in part in terms of how big they are
like if you take
10 chunky areas and you add them
together the total is less chunky yeah
but don't you are you able until you
solve
the fundamental core
parts of the problem to estimate the
chunkiness of that problem
well if you have a history of prior
chunkiness that could be your best
estimate for future chunkiness so for
example i mean even at the level of the
world economy right we've had this what
10 000 years of
civilization well that's only a short
time
you might say oh that that doesn't
predict future chunkiness
uh but you know it looks relatively
steady and consistent
we can say even in computer science
we've had you know seven years of
computer science we have enough data to
look at chunkiness in computer science
like when were there algorithms or
approaches that made a big chunky
difference and you know
versus and how large a fraction of that
was that and i'd say mostly in computer
science most innovation has been
relatively small chunks the bigger
chunks have been rare
well this is the interesting thing this
is about ai and just algorithms in
general
is
you know page rank uh so google's right
so
sometimes it's a simple algorithm that
by itself
is not that useful but the scalar
context and in the context that's
scalable like right depending on the
yeah depending on the context is all of
a sudden the power is revealed and
there's something i guess that's the
nature of chunkiness
is um
that you get things that can reach a lot
of people simply
can be quite chunky so one standard
story about algorithms is to say
algorithms have a fixed cost plus a
marginal cost
and so
in history when you had computers that
were very small you tried all the
algorithms had low fixed costs
and you look for the best of those but
over time as computers got bigger you
could afford to do larger fixed costs
and try those and some of those had
more effective algorithms in terms of
their marginal cost
and that
in fact you know that it roughly
explains the long-term history where in
fact the rate of algorithmic improvement
is about the same as the rate of
hardware improvement
which is a remarkable coincidence
but it would be explained by saying well
there's all these better algorithms you
can't try until you have a big enough
computer to pay the fixed cost of doing
some trials to find out if that
algorithm actually saves you on the
marginal cost
and so
that's an explanation for this
relatively continuous history where so
we have a good story about why hardware
is so contiguous right and you might
think why would software be so
continuous
with the hardware but if there's a
distribution of algorithms in terms of
their fixed costs and it's safe spread
out at a wide log normal distribution
then we could be sort of marching
through that log normal distribution
trying out algorithms with larger fixed
costs and finding the ones that have
lower marginal cost
so
would you say agi human level
ai
even em
m
emulated minds
is uh chunky
like a few breakthroughs can take so and
m is by its nature chunky in the sense
that if you have an emulated brain and
you're 25 effective at emulating it
that's crap that's nothing
okay okay
you pretty much need to emulate a full
human brain is that obvious
is that obvious that it's pretty obvious
i'm talking about like you know
so the key thing is you're emulating
various brain cells and so you have to
emulate the input output pattern of
those cells so if you get that pattern
somewhat close but not close enough then
the whole system just doesn't have the
overall behavior you're looking for
right but it could have functionally
some of the power of the overall so
there'll be some threshold the question
is when you get close enough then it
goes over the threshold it's like taking
a computer chip and deleting every one
percent of the of the gates right no
that's that's very chunky but uh right
hope is that the emulating the human
brain i mean the human brain itself is
not right so it has a certain level of
redundancy and a certain robustness and
so there's some threshold when you get
close to that level of redundancy and
robustness then it starts to work but
until you you know until you get to that
level it's just going to be crap right
it's going to be just a big thing that
isn't working well so we can be pretty
sure that emulations is is a big chunk
in an economic sense right at some point
you'll be able to make one that's
actually effective
in enable substituting for humans and
then that will be this huge economic
product that people will try to buy
crazy now you'll bring a lot of value to
people's lives so they'll be able
they'll be willing to pay for it
but it could be that you know the first
emulation costs a billion dollars each
right and then we have them but we can't
really use them too expensive then the
cost slowly comes down and now we have
less of a chunky adaptation adoption
right
that as the cross comes down then we use
more and more of them in more and more
contexts
and that's a more continuous curve
so it's only if the first emulations are
relatively cheap that you get of more
sudden disruption to society
and that could happen if sort of the
algorithm is the last thing you figure
out how to do or something what about
robots that capture some magic
um
in terms of social connection
the robots like we have a robot dog on
the carpet right there uh
robots that are able to capture some
magic of human connection
as they interact with humans but are not
emulating the brain what about what
about those how far away
so
we're thinking about chunkiness or
distance now so if you ask how chunky is
the task of making a you know emulatable
robot or something you know a which
chunkiness and time are correlated right
but that it's about how far away it is
or how suddenly it would happen
uh chunkiness is how suddenly
and you know difficulty is just how far
away it is but it could be a continuous
difficulty it would just be far away but
will slowly steadily get there or there
could be these thresholds where we reach
a threshold and suddenly we can do a lot
better yeah that's a good i mean
question for both i tend to believe that
all of it not just the m
but agi too is chunky
and
um human level intelligence so my best
body in robots is also junk because the
history of computer science and
chunkiness so far seems to be my rough
best guess for the chunkiness of agi
that is
it is chunky it's modestly chunky not
that chunky right because
our ability chunks peanut butter too
many things in the economy has been
moving relatively steadily overall in
terms of our use of computers in society
they have been relatively steadily
improving for 70 years no but i would
say that's hard well yeah okay
okay i would have to really think about
that because uh neural networks are
quite surprising
sure but every once in a while we have a
new thing that's surprising but if you
if you stand back you know we see
something like that every 10 10 years or
so something new innovation is gradual
that has a big effect
so moderately chunky
huh
yeah the history of the level of
disruption we've seen in the past would
be a rough estimate of the level of
disruption in the future unless the
future is we're going to hit a chunky
territory much chunkier than we've seen
in the past well i do think there's um
it's like uh like kunian like revolution
type
it
it seems like the data especially on
ai's
is is difficult to um
uh to reason with because it's so recent
it's such a recent field
in this been around for 50 years
i mean 50 60 70 80 years being recent
okay that's the that's
it's enough time to see a lot of trends
a lot a few trends a few trends i think
the internet
computing
there's really a lot of interesting
stuff that's happened over the past 30
years
that
i think the possibility of revolutions
is likelier than it was
in the i think for the last 70 years
there have always been a lot of things
that look like they had a potential for
evolution so we can't reason well about
this i mean i think we can reason well
by looking at the past trends i would
say the past trend is roughly your best
guess for the future
features but if i look back at the at
the things that might have looked like
revolutions in the 70s and 80s and 90s
uh
they are less like the revolutions
of that appear to be happening now or
the capacity of revolution that appear
to be there now first of all there's a
lot of more money to be made
so there's a lot more incentive for
markets to do a lot of kind of
innovation it seems like in the ai space
but uh then again there's a history of
winters and summers and so on so maybe
we're just like riding a nice wave right
now one of the biggest issues is the
difference between impressive demos and
commercial value yes so we often through
the history of ai we saw very impressive
demos that never really translated much
into commercial values somebody who
works on and cares about autonomous and
semi-autonomous vehicles tell me about
it so and there again we return to the
number of elon musks per earth
per year yeah generated
uh
that's the um coincidentally the same
initials as the m uh yeah
very suspicious very suspicious we're
gonna have to look into that
you